in sankt johann im pongau sind die
krampusse los der nikolaus mit seinen
engeln führt die wüsten gestalten durch
den ort und mittendrin eindeutig zu
erkennen
st johann am morgen ich bin unterwegs in
den board hier knapp 60 kilometer
südlich von salzburg in österreich wird
die tradition des campus gepflegt sowie
in der ganzen region
ich treffe den gründer einer krampus
gruppe bericht mitte der 80er jahre hat
er eine sogenannte pass gegründet die
besteht aus einem nikolaus engeln einem
korbleger und mehr als einem dutzend
krampusse aber krampus oder aufrecht
genannt ist er schon seit kinder da
auf dem zwölften lebensjahr da läuft
somit in den orten in den verschiedenen
und dann sagst du hier bestimmen aber
was auf die beine schauen wir mal bei
freunden und so hat es angefangen mit
neun stück und jetzt sind wir inzwischen
18 märkten nicolas zwei enkeln corp
träger und jetzt werde zwar was los ist
jetzt gehen wir sumpf ziehen und dort
geht's los geht's da jetzt mal für dich
da seid ihr dran du musst die aber jetzt
die hose aus dienst ok bricht ja ganz
ehrlich das mit dem ausziehen das hatten
hier vorgetragener gesagt
der grund ist ganz einfach auch bei
minustemperaturen wird es in dem schafe
land rover dass jede hose darunter ist
völlig überflüssig ist so einen anzug
hält ungefähr fünf jahre dann ist das
leder porös und reist dann als nächstes
kommt der schellen goethe mit dem die
krampusse lärm schlagen und zum schluss
die maske alles zusammen wiegt 30 kilo
in dem anzug und klima geschenkt ich
kann kaum spreche ich sie so gut wie
nicht wie nur durch den augenschlitzen
besuchte mund und ich weiß noch nicht
wie ich diesen tag über stehen dort
alles egal denn jetzt wird es ernst
vorne weg geht der nikolaus mit seinen
engeln und dem korb träger dahinter das
ist eher an laut hier besuchen einen
bauernhof am rand
sei gegrüßt bei diesem haus
jetzt spricht der nikolaus da hier nur
artige kinder wohnen bekommen alle ein
geschenk vom nikolaus wir krampusse
halten uns eher im hintergrund die
schiere masse der masken wird von ganz
allein
danach beginnt der gemütliche teil des
besuchs wir also die körpers ist von der
familie eingeladen waren
für die kinder ist es jedes jahr schon
wochen vorher suhr erlebnis das die
krampe zu uns und natürlich als nikolaus
und die engel zu uns offizier man also
sie haben damals gerade weil ist einfach
ein highlight das in der adventszeit ist
da freut man sich dann noch mehr auf
weihnachten hat ganz nikolaus sehen
einfach gesagt zur installation
dann geht es weiter zum nächsten
auftritt art gerecht werden krampusse im
sie anhänger transportiert insgesamt
haben wir heute viel hausbesuche an
manchen tagen können es auch doppelt so
viel sei in der guten stube unserer
vorletzten station ist es kuschelig warm
[Musik]
mir läuft im feld der schweiß in strömen
durch die enge maske kann ich kaum atmen
ich bin kurz davor aufzugeben nach einer
schier endlosen bescherung und einem
zweiten weihnachtslied ist es endlich
vorbei
[Musik]
vielen dank
unser bester schlussmann
[Gelächter]
aber ganz geschafft habe ich es noch
nicht die menschen in sankt johann
erwarten uns zum krampuslauf hier
präsentieren sich mehr als ein dutzend
gruppen aus dem ort und wir vorne
[Musik]
geschafft und ich bin völlig fertig nach
sieben stunden in diesem ganzkörper
schaffeld das sprichwort schmoren im
eigenen dach noch mal eine ganz neue
bedeutung bekommen was wir auf jeden
fall am meisten gefallen hat ist die tat
hat mich sofort aufgenommen hat als sei
ich einer von ihnen und ich finde auf
jeden fall um eine erfahrung reicher